thank you so much for doing this i'm a
huge fan of your work so this is a joke
oh
that's very generous thanks so much um
you know we're celebrating
10 years of super eight i want to ask
you a question that i have wanted to ask
you for almost a decade at this point
the audio commentary track of that film
uh you and larry fong and brian burke
are uh trying to get steven spielberg to
answer a question
and he does not respond to the email
during the commentary i was wondering if
he ever responded to that email
i believe the question was why don't you
do dvd commentaries
well that's hilarious uh you know i
don't
that was ten years ago so i apologize i
don't remember if he ever responded but
um
[Music]
you know i i think that uh if i could
guess i think it's that he sort of likes
to
you know keep his
sort of secrets to uh to himself but um
i don't i don't know if he ever
responded that uh but i'll ask him again
okay yeah i know your guys's gambit was
that was the way to get him to actually
do a dvd commentary so i read
his answer well i uh that's true
actually i i i wish he had but i um
i will i will try to find out though
okay um well i know that the you know
the legend behind this movie is that it
it was
two stories one uh was about kids with
super 8 cameras
making your own movies and then one was
like an alien one that was combined
i was here is that true i mean that's
kind of the lore around uh you know how
the story was created
you know when i when i reached out to
stephen to ask if if he would be
interested in doing
uh a movie called super 8
about kids making super 8 movies uh and
he said yes
i didn't really necessarily have in my
head
that there would be a monster although i
think i i had the thought that there
would be some
intrigue that they would sort of stumble
upon uh you know in a kind of you know
uh blow up blowout sort of way where
it's like there's something
you know that they see that they uh
you know gets them sort of sucked into a
something where they're in over their
heads and
uh as steve and i started
meeting and talking about what it could
be this idea came up and
you know i feel like while i don't think
i ever completely
reconciled the the two sort of genres
and in a way i think doing something
that was
simply about the kids could have been um
you know maybe even a a more
satisfying story there was something
given that that as we were discussing
what this movie could be the the feeling
of it being
you know an amblin movie that it would
feel like something sort of from that
library
in fact this is the first amblin movie
uh to have the
the title card at the beginning of the
movie as opposed to the end
and i think that that that was part of
the the
sort of genre mash-up thing was that
amblin movies traditionally did that and
and it felt like something that that
would have
allowed it to live on a shelf more
comfortably with with
those other films i know that the way
you like to work you like to keep
uh you know the production a little bit
loose open to uh
you know other creative ideas that might
come about um
not to say that there's not a script but
you know i i know on the dvd come to you
talk about liking to work with kyle
chandler because he had come from friday
night lights
where that was similar and i was curious
how working with kids
uh changes that like does it make it
easier or does it make it harder to kind
of be open to different ideas while
you're working well it's a
it's a funny thing you know working with
kids is by nature
a less predictable experience and so i
think you have to go into that as much
as you can
embracing the fact that you're not quite
sure what you're gonna get um
but the truth is that working with grown
actors and
really accomplished uh and and sort of
proven actors
usually they're so good because they're
gonna also surprise you and and do
something that
you know changes the tone or the dynamic
or or you know
sometimes even the you know the the
physicality of the scene you know how
something is is choreographed
but i feel like with kids uh especially
you know this group they were so sort of
rambunctious and so
funny together and would sort of push
each other's buttons and
be making to their laugh and while they
were actually
also really thoughtful and serious it
was you know it was it was a funny
experience being with these
these kids and seeing how their dynamic
would change enormously when el fanning
was on set like all of a sudden when she
was there they would just you know
uh act very differently and that was
always every single time that was that
was hilarious but
you have to kind of be willing to go
with
the unexpected with kids and and
especially given that the way
who they played what they were doing
that sometimes you know running the
camera without them
even being aware was part of the fun of
it too which is sort of like
let them think that you're setting the
thing up but you're actually rolling
and you know sometimes we got some some
pieces that were really
you know great especially in the diner
scene
well in talking about you know the
monster the monster is very much a
metaphor for joe's grief and you know
the film builds to this really emotional
climax where
you know he's talking to the monster and
he's really telling the monster what he
needs to hear
and i'm curious how you as the director
kind of went about
building towards that moment while also
making a monster that
is scary and terrifying and you know was
killing people like kind of
marrying those two ideas while you're
crafting the story
yeah i mean i think that the you know
the the
notion was like you said that that this
was a kid who was
trying to process the loss of of his
mother
and that this thing that he had to
confront who who he had to get right up
to and
look in the eyes and and who had to see
him um
yes this thing was scary and it was
awful and it was a thing of nightmares
uh but it was also the thing that that
he had to connect with to understand and
then to
to get past and and to have leave him
and you know i i often think that the
the the movie is the story that the main
character has to experience
to become enlightened and
and even though of course this is like a
crazy nightmare if
if if joe went to sleep one night um
maybe the night of his mother's memorial
service
and had this dream it's not to say he'd
wake up without feeling any grief but
the idea that
it would have been a thing that he
emotionally felt that he had
uh some kind of gauntlet that he had
passed through that he
you know some some kind of experience
that allowed him to
grapple with and and and overcome his
grief in some way you know um
and and and allowing him to let go
finally
uh not to say he doesn't love his mother
or that he
you know won't miss her but the idea
that he's sort of
you know in denial in some way and sort
of holding on to this thing and and
somehow letting go of that
feels like the thing that um you know
that locket represents this
you know this connection that that he he
had to just finally be okay with her
not being there and weirdly this
ridiculous monster did that so
having scenes of of terror or or
you know fear or mystery with this
monster suspense you know where you feel
that this thing is out there
it was a way of of you know
of dramatizing what kind of internal
strife joe was going through
well i'm curious i mean that this is an
original story it's an original sci-fi
film
um nowadays it feels like a lot of
original stories have to be packaged
into ip
in order for those films to get made i'm
just curious from your perspective do
you think super eight would be made
as is today in today's climate or do you
feel like it would have to be a
cloverfield movie would it have to have
something
you know giving it that x-men or not you
know i i feel incredibly uh
grateful to steven for uh doing this
with me and obviously to paramount for
letting get made because like you said
it's something that i think is is more
anomalous than not that a movie would
get made that
didn't have some connection to it uh
you know even you know frankly some of
the
movies that i've i've loved recently
like you know even the invisible man
which of course
was about an invisible man so calling it
the invisible man makes sense
and yet it could have been called
anything um it was its own story it was
an original and unique story so
i i feel like uh i feel very lucky to
have gotten to make this movie and
have some other things that i i'm
working on that are also in an original
space and
and hope to make those as well but you
know time will tell
yeah i mean that's not to do i mean
black panther is no less brilliant
because it's based on a comic but you
know
the truth oh far less original stories
being told right but i mean but but to
your point like i've i've heard
i've heard pitches for things that
use existing titles but the stories that
are being pitched are so
specific and unique that
you realize it doesn't have to be that
that title
yeah and and and you know i think that
that like you said that is sort of the
norm now
hopefully will change yeah well i'm
curious i mean
one of the things i liked about the star
wars franchise
that you guys did was that the creative
handoff between you and ryan johnson
which i felt
you know it was letting filmmakers take
their own stories and take
take the story where they wanted to go
and i felt that played out in a really
interesting way
but i know not everyone feels that way
and i'm curious for you as the person
who helped get that foundation off the
ground and also concluded it
do you feel like that trilogy would have
benefited from planning out
a very strict three movie story from the
very beginning
or do you enjoy that kind of creative
freedom to kind of take the characters
different ways and kind of see how it
goes
you know i i've been involved in a
number of of
projects that have been um
uh you know in most case
series that have
ideas that begin the thing where you
feel like you know where it's gonna go
and then sometimes it's an actor who
comes in
uh other times it's a relationship that
as it's written doesn't quite work and
things that you think are going to just
you know be so well received um
just crash and burn and other things
that you think like oh that's a little
small moment that's a one-episode
character suddenly become a hugely
important part of the
the story and i feel like what i've
learned as a
lesson a few times now and it's
something that that in
especially in this pandemic
year uh working with writers
the lesson is that you know you you have
to plan things the best you can and
and you always need to be able to
respond to
the unexpected and the unexpected can
come in all sorts of forms
and i just i do think that uh you know
there's there's nothing more important
than
knowing where you're going and there are
projects that i've worked on where
we had some ideas but we we hadn't
worked through them enough we had some
sometimes we had some ideas but then we
weren't allowed to do them the way we
wanted to
we had i mean i've had all sorts of
situations where
um you know uh
you you you plan things in a certain way
and you suddenly find yourself doing
something that's 180 degrees different
um and then sometimes it works really
well
and you feel like wow that really came
together and other times you think oh my
god
i can't believe this is where we are and
sometimes when it's not working out it's
because it's what you planned
and other times when it's not working
out it's because it didn't it's like you
just you you never really know but
but having a plan you know i have
learned in some cases the hard way
um is the most you know critical thing
because otherwise
you don't know what you're setting up
you don't know what you're
you know uh what to emphasize because if
you don't know the inevitable
of the story you know you're just as
good as your
last you know sequence or or
effect or joke or whatever but you want
to be leading to something inevitable
for sure um well i have to rap with you
pretty soon but i did want to ask and i
know full well the irony of this
question but because of the people
involved i'm excited about it
the superman movie as someone who has
written
a superman movie before that didn't go
into production i was curious what
uh sparked to you about tanasi coates
about having him write
uh you know a superman movie a uh a new
version of this character
well i i honestly cannot wait um
and would love to to talk about it with
you uh
when the time is right um but i will
just say it's something that we are
incredibly excited about and i think
that anyone who gets to work with tahasi
is blessed so i feel very lucky to uh
to get to be collaborating with him well
and on the original side uh project
yours i'm very excited for is demi monde
uh i hope i'm pronouncing that right
yeah is that still
uh in development is that something that
might be happening soon uh it is we've
uh we've had a
a terrific writer's room for about a
year and
we are um to you know
the point earlier about the the pandemic
one of the
sort of remarkable um
and unexpected uh benefits of this
otherwise trying and in many cases
painful time
has been that the projects that that
we've been working on uh
have been allowed to gestate and
and you know simmer and the writing has
been able to
happen without that more typical
urgency of of pre-production and
production where suddenly
you're looking at locations and
auditions and set design and production
design and props and things
when you're just trying to figure out
the bones and the framework and so the
the
beauty of this this time on demand for
example
is we've been able to not just
outline the season but right this season
um and not just
you know roughly understand where we
want to go over the course of the series
but actually plot it out and so i feel
like we're
you know we're in a place that feels
like it should be more the norm than it
ever is
uh to really kind of know where you're
going to go but to your earlier question
that was a really good one about
about planning things out i just feel
like you know that that's one of the
things that
has you know this time has allowed us to
do in a way that i don't think
we've ever had the uh the luxury before
i can't wait to see that
very quickly awesome obligated as a
writer for collider to ask
about collider i know it's a project
that's been in development for a long
time that you and i are
working on is that still bubbling up or
is that kind of
edgar has since gone off to do you know
a few other movies and and it's it's not
something that that is actively
in the works right now but it you know
obviously it's an idea that i
i love that edgar came to me with and
um you know he's a dear friend and i
can't wait to
do something with him but uh i don't
know if clyde is going to be it awesome
well thank you again so much for taking
the time
uh my pleasure thank you i really can't
really appreciate this project cheers
thank you thank you take care